fathers on men and boys because in my
opinion it is a serious serious
detriment when boys don't have a man a
dad in their life
um I grew up and did a lot of
dysfunctional things that I think I
would have been steered away from or
shielded from
again just like what what I said at the
beginning of the show you know
um I was looking for I found I was kind
of looking for family outside on the
street and it led me to you know just
pay crimes you know addictive behavior
and stuff like that so I just want to
get you lots take on it like the
importance of fathers on Sons because we
talked about how the fathers are
important for doors so what do you think
about the sun to start over there
say that again sorry the question so the
importance the importance of fathers for
sons
yeah I think it's key
uh
I can only say from one side I grew out
of that father doesn't mean there's
stuff as a Young Man
or Boy turning into that you know I mean
turning into a man that you need a
father figure so if I don't know it's
hard because I can only say from my view
what okay what what things do you think
you feel that you lacked because I know
what I feel I lacked um
I feel like I was freestyling a lot as a
boy as a teenager I was freestyle
because I didn't know no one was telling
me look this is how it is this is how
girls are you know you're gonna meet
some type of friends that are gonna lead
you down this road and stuff like that
it's kind of like I was just out there
you know your mom tries to tell you that
she's not a man she she hasn't done it
she's just going off what she thinks you
know what I mean and then if our moms
didn't have that damn self
he's kind of you know he's difficult in
it see what I'm saying so I feel like I
was freestyling I was just making up as
I go along and I made a lot of mistakes
that were unnecessary bro like I didn't
need to like getting nicked all the time
and stuff like that like it was
unnecessary so that's what I'm really
kind of like getting at like the things
that the things you feel like you lacked
because I feel like I'll say one more
thing yeah
um dealing how to deal with certain
situations like conflict and
confrontation as you're saying because
obviously men we we tend to be more
logic based we we tend to not act
irrationally of emotion like quick to
anger like my mom [ __ ] like Nigerian
lady quick to anger straight away like
straight away like you know what I'm
saying like where is like men will more
be inclined to Not all men some men are
like that as well but but
I feel like I kind of lost that and
growing up I was quick to anger whereas
I could have been more logic based more
like rationally rational based in it so
that emotional side was a bit too high
and I think that a lot of boys that grow
up with just their mom they kind of take
on that feminine energy of being like
too emotional like oh someone stepped on
my shoes now I want to shank them you
get what I'm saying so what do you think
about that like you said the emotional
side when you're saying it earlier when
you grow up without a dad someone in
school says your mum or something is a
big like you said the emotional you
react it don't even mean nothing your
mom what they say what I mean and if you
did have a father you got that guidance
to say listen it don't matter and I feel
that that's what you lack when you ain't
got that guidance
or you might have it from your mum but
it's a different type of guidance so if
you have it from your dad
then you're automatically going to be
going down a different path because they
they know all the pros and cons that
come with being a man your mum don't
know that especially you've heard that
us that she didn't have a dad herself
how can she be in a position to speak
from experience so you've got nothing to
learn from all you're doing is literally
being told something how do you agree
with that or how do you how do you live
by that like you said you feel with
feelings you know I mean or you act with
feeling and basic actions speak louder
than words so you need you need your
father figure there so when you when you
let that
you look for it elsewhere and like you
said it could lead you down the wrong
path but it's a concoction of bad things
so when you look at the absence of
masculinity that doesn't tell you how to
control your emotions but then when
you're looking at the ages of 16 to 25
that's when testosterone is heightened
and that's why when you look at prison
rates the the majority is 16 to 25
because you've got your hormones all in
your head got you all [ __ ] up and
you're and then you're being told the
ideas of hyper masculinity is if a man
looks at you wrong bang him in the face
but your father would be dare to tell
you that son this is how you manage your
emotions this is you taking your first
steps to becoming a man and what it
actually means to be a man because in
the end you're taught a man is someone
that deals with deals with things with
violence whereas you when you grow up
you realize a man is someone that takes
care of his problems even when he
doesn't want to yeah but as a kid you
don't understand that no unless again
back to the guidance that's what you
need from your father and then when you
obviously when you when you grow up in a
single household just with your mum like
you said that's where you lack heavily
and that's probably the most the main
thing as you said from 16 to 25 probably
key points that you need a father there
and when you don't have that like you
said the prison rates are high and
that's what happens unfortunately when
you're from where we're from
but then then as a girl you end up being
a 304 or end up being a slack for the UK
people because your your Dad's shoes to
respect yourself yeah that guy can take
you two two calamari and you're like
yeah this is love hey you sound like you
calamari twice
all right all right okay I want to hear
your opinion what do you think about it
so my opinion is a bit sticky the reason
being I say that yeah both Mama and Dad
was at home however I still stared off
and did my own things but reason being
why I felt like that was because
I felt like I was still missing out
bearing in mind I said my parents ain't
born here so as I'm first generation
right I'm looking at things that they're
telling me and I'm like but I'm looking
at everyone else as well and I'm looking
at all my friends and I feel like I'm
missing out so I feel like when you're
saying these things I'm not really
hearing or understanding I don't you
they may have gone through it yeah but I
feel like um
where they're not from here their level
of going through it is not the same so
therefore I'm not really acknowledging
what they're saying and I'm still going
out and doing whatever the hell I need
to do at that specific time and yeah
testosterone building up now you I've
got to Define myself as a man do you
understand even though I've got my dad
is not to say I could still say yeah
what get my dad to come down like a
couple of my bedrooms who did have dads
but you can tell that their dad was yeah
he was outside I was gonna say because
that's interesting it's like those kind
of those kind of boys with them kind of
does it's like their dad was born here
yeah did you understand and they
understand they understand yeah so it's
I feel like it's a different guidance
whereas when you're not born here even
though
because a lot of people think right but
your mom and dad are together like why
are we doing whatever they still doing
magic do you understand but it's it's
not that it's like I still gotta make my
name kind of thing because my dad's not
from here so even though the teachings
he's going to teach me where he's
probably gone through it where he was
from it's not the same here you ain't
got to deal with this I I personally
didn't believe at the time he's dealing
with the same things I've got to deal
with I I can't see even on my dad's at
home I can't say I'm gonna go and get my
dad on my older brother I'm the oldest
do you understand so still kind of
making my own name for okay cool trouble
my younger siblings they can say that so
it's like a slight disconnect yeah
because our culture's like black British
culture whereas they're from wherever
they're from but as many of you know I
was just banned on Tic Tac and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible